foreign
on an affair with another married man I
lost a lot of respect for my sister I
wish my sister would show some remorse
for what she did to her family but it
doesn't feel like she is at least hear
her out I would get on an airplane and
go fly and sit with her
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney show and I'm so so
grateful that you've joined us
talking about mental health talking
about your emotional health your
marriage your parenting whatever you got
going on in your life your money even
um there's more and more discussion
across the country about mental health
and money we will talk about whatever is
going on in your life on this show I'm
so grateful that you've joined us and
here's my promise this shows is real
people going through real stuff they
call from all over the world and my
promise is I'm not always going to know
everything but I promise I'll tell you
the truth and I promise I'll sit with
you so if you want to be on the show go
to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k fill out the form and it will
go to Jenna and Kelly and they will get
it get it in there get you lined up for
the show and um
if you'll take a quick second and just
like subscribe send this episode
everybody you know somebody's struggling
with whatever we're going to talk about
today as they come in
um I love love love love for you to pass
the show along last thing housekeeping
wise don't forget my brand new book
building a non-anxious life is out for
pre-sale you can go to John deloney.com
we'll send you a whole bunch of stuff
you can download as soon as you buy it
you can download a talk I gave to
several thousand folks
um on one of the chapters in this book
um about choosing Freedom
um whenever I say that I always expect
like a like an eagle to go ah and fly
across the room or whatever it's not
what I'm talking about but
um building a non-anxious life listen
um I'll say this with as much directness
and and clarity as I can
more people
are being medicated for mental health
disorders right now than ever before in
human history
I've benefited from those medicines okay
not anti-medicine
but more people right now are medicated
than ever before
more people are under the care of a
licensed mental health professional than
ever before in human history I actually
am too I get it
but when we look globally we look at our
local communities we look at our country
the rates of anxiety and depression are
continuing to Skyrocket
and so as a mental health guy as a guy
that that
um
sees a mental health professional
I have to step back and I have to look
at the bigger picture and say hey
what we're doing is not working
and it pains me to say that I went to
college for this I have spent my career
doing this what we're doing at a at a
large scale isn't working
do counselors help are you kidding me of
course they do does is there times when
medication helps yes do we weigh over
prescribe medication no doubt about it
but is there times it helps absolutely
but globally what we're doing is not
working so we have to go back and
re-examine these lives that we're
leading that are causing all these
things in the first place
and that was the that's the Genesis of
this book building a non-anxious life
because everybody's talking about I want
to be less anxious I want to be less
burned out I want to be less stressed
what are some tips and some tricks since
we're not at tips and tricks anymore
we're past that now we gotta go back to
the roots of these issues and solve
these challenges and my promise is if
you create a non-anxious life
the anxiety alarms stop ringing your
body stops trying to get your attention
and tell you that you're not safe
or you have some true mental health
disorders and thank God we live in it in
a time in a place when there's trained
professionals that can help those folks
who are really really struggling
um
so check it out building a non-anxious
life go to John deloney.com you can pick
it up for 20 bucks and we'll send you a
whole bunch of stuff I think they're
through in a pony and a
bag of balloons or something I don't
know whatever all right let's go out to
Lauren in Washington DC what's up Lauren
hey Dr John how are you good how are you
doing thanks for dealing with our
technical issues how we doing
hey because I'm diagnosed with bipolar
disorder and
um have had a lot of issues running up
credit cards in the past during manic
episodes but the past two years I've
been episode free was able to pay off
all the debt and I'm on baby steps four
five and six now but there's still this
undercurrent of anxiety that I'm going
to do that again in the future and ruin
my finances again so I'm wondering what
advice you may have about that yeah you
bet let's um number one like before we
even dig in
um what you just said I hope you know
this that's in it's incredible what you
just said
it's incredible it's very rare for me to
talk to somebody in this in this uh on
the phone like this they call into the
show uh who write into the show
that there's that they've been diagnosed
with bipolar they're living with it and
then they go on to pay off all their for
years
that's amazing
it's really really incredible it's a
testament to how hard you're working on
all this
um bipolar one or two
uh two two so
um
tell me about not the manic phases tell
me about the dark phases
um I've had a suicide attempt in the
past and usually when it's I'm having
depression it can get sometimes when
it's really bad difficult for me to
function at work
and difficult for me to get out the
house and do the things I normally like
to do like hang out with friends and
just normal activities that I would
usually find fun are draining yeah so
for everybody listening bipolar is is
can be bipolar one or bipolar two
bipolar two is generally noted as
hypomanic meaning the Mania stage the
the the parts when everything spins up
may not be quite as high as bipolar one
but
um it's often
partnered with a deeper or a more
Sinister if you will
um depressive episode and when people
who don't experience depression Lauren
hear phrases like depressive episode it
just is like ah whatever can you paint a
picture of waking up when you're in the
black hole if you think back to those
times are you on meds now
I I am medicated but very minimally like
much less than what most people with my
diagnosis are medicated with I I want to
applaud you for that too
one of the biggest challenges of loving
and caring and walking alongside folks
who struggle with bipolars that when
they when they feel well they feel
amazing and they slowly will stop taking
their meds or they'll completely stop
taking them and then they end up right
back where they were and so for you high
five
high five I mean you're like you're just
like rock star in this thing
um think back to some times before you
had everything leveled out
give us a description of what it feels
like to open your eyes in those mornings
wow
well usually
the first thing that I'll think of is
just that I wish I could go back to
sleep I don't want to do this
um just very low energy even if
I drink coffee it's just
feels like my body is heavier than it
usually is hard to talk to people I'm
usually
more fun to be around and people enjoy
hanging out with me and I can usually
tell when I'm in those depressive spaces
that
people aren't enjoying my presence as
much
I've heard it described as feeling like
you're trapped inside of a pillow
or trapped under water and people trying
to talk to you and everything's a little
bit fuzzy it's just exhausting and I
just would rather not not be trying to
listen to what you're saying and hear
what you're saying and interact with you
the lights feel like they're too bright
like everything just feels like too much
and
yeah it's that you used a word I've
heard often heavy it's just like
everything feels like I'm just full of
sand right yeah
and
you have worked your butt off to be
where you are
right now it's incredible so tell me
about this anxiety that's that's
haunting you
well even though I'm doing pretty good
I'll
um I think the Mania is more what I'm
scared of because the depression I've
become accustomed to the Mania I really
felt outside of myself and acted in ways
that I never act when I'm in my normal
state of mind so even though I've have
you know a good emergency fund
um
if I get too excited about something or
sometimes it gets to like any sort of
happy emotion there will be a thought
that comes in later like oh well is this
Mania are you about to have another
episode are you gonna
spend all your money again and uh
horrible situations your skin and the
environment all the time
because you've lost trust in your body
and you're wondering when uh are we
going are we going are we going no no no
no that was just too much caffeine or uh
here we go here we go oh no that was
just because I was annoyed and so it's
hard to decipher what are
and I hate to use this kind of language
but it's we just got a short time
together normal feelings right of anger
frustration excitement or I'm really
jazzed up versus oh no my body's
spinning up and we're gonna spend three
or four days
or a week or two weeks just running and
gunning and running gunning right and so
you live in this kind of tension you
don't wanna do you feel find yourself
de-escalating things on purpose
to try to keep your body from what do
you mean by that
um if you feel real excited about
something and then all of a sudden
you're talking really fast and your
friends are laughing really hard and you
cut it's euphoric right it feels awesome
and you're going and going do you find
yourself trying to throttle it back
because you're scared of your own body
yeah
yes that's
definitely right like
yeah you end up duct taping over like
normal life experiences which are
awesome and there's nothing better than
being around a bunch of friends and
you're all hanging out and everyone
starts laughing so hard milk's coming
out your eyeballs and your nose and
everything
ah it's frustrating all right so
the good news is
um you are a
unique yet rock star example
of somebody who's
fought through hell and back
who's working with a medical
professional who's doing what you got to
do even when you don't feel like it
and who is working hard to be in tune
with your own body
that sets you apart and I need you to
hear me say I'm so proud of you it's
amazing
okay what that tells me is you have at
least turned the corner on
I'm trying to live with Lauren I'm not
I'm not going to war with her anymore
is that fair
yes that tells me you love Lauren which
is awesome
okay yeah that's good to hear it's a lot
I mean I just want you to drop your
shoulders it's really incredible and I
it's frustrating because you're like I
don't like to feel like this all the
time though and if you're telling me I'm
doing great and this is great I don't
like that
I want you to lean on it okay it's
amazing second thing is here's the not
good news
um it's gonna take time
to learn to continue to trust your body
it's just a process of trust trust trust
and then you're going to have mishaps
there's gonna be times when your body
spins out on you again and you're gonna
have to learn to be really graceful with
yourself
and then here's the important part
you're gonna have to build really strong
boundaries
what does that look like I don't have
bipolar too
there has been Seasons when I gave up my
debit cards to my wife
I got rid of the my Amazon login
because I was out of control
and I could talk to myself all day long
like all right dude we're just gonna
and I I just would buy everything
and what though I would buy stupid like
I would pick up the tab for people I
didn't even know I'd be like I'm buying
that guy's a lot like it just gets out
it's almost out of body right doesn't
make any sense and I don't have bipolar
too I'm not dealing with you're that
you're talking you're on jet fuel here
so I literally had to give stuff away
sometimes it was for a month or two like
I had to just create some significant
space Here's the word I want you to
think of hurdles
what are some ways I can put hurdles
between me and these behaviors that I
know are going to cause me problems
um if you're if you had in one of in
manic phases if you had a lot of sexual
acting out which is a common thing in
both one and two
I might tell you to I want you to delete
all of the phone numbers in your cell
phone oh folks you have hooked up with
before let's delete all of them
and at least make it hard for yourself
to have to you'd have to go through a
bunch of Hoops to track it down and my
hope is at some point you have enough
cognition to go
um
oh or at least I'm going to reach out to
somebody and say hey I'm I'm trying to
do what I can to find people so if you
struggled with
um
uh binge eating I would tell you get all
the junk out of the house
right so I want you to create a whole
bunch of hurdles between you and
yourself and it may be as much as
calling the bank
and saying
I can only spend this much
at a time unless I call you specifically
will that be a pain on a day-to-day
basis yeah but will that keep you from
waking up one week and weekend and
realizing you just drained all your
savings yeah that'd be awesome too
does that make sense
yeah I like I like the idea of hurdles
okay barriers in place to protect give
me an example of one that you think you
could put in your life right now
I think I can
call my parents
um and
have them have access to
my my bank information I have that
relationship I can do that with my dad
he would
he would be a good barrier to put in
place I think it'd be pretty amazing if
you sat down with your dad how did you
learn
29 29 dude that's you're so amazing I I
I think it would be great if you sat
down with your dad and said Dad I'm
about to be 30. I'm entering into a new
phase of adulthood and I'm creating
boundaries in my life because this is
this is right I'm gonna live with this
forever and I'm continuing continuing to
get healthier and healthier
um but I want some accountability that's
the magic word would you
um be my accountability person when it
came to money
and if you have a trusting relationship
like that with him that would be
incredible Lauren
be amazing and you also have a job to do
and that is to find one or two friends
in your life that you could develop that
friendship and cultivate that
relationship with them over time
that they could be that person for for
you because your dad won't always be
there
um and I've got a couple of buddies my
buddy Craig
my buddy Todd a buddy John like those
guys are close friends my buddy Kevin I
asked them money questions I trust them
with all I have
and
um if I'm getting out of control or
being ridiculous those are guys that
will step in and be like whoa whoa what
are you doing what are you doing and so
um they don't all have access to my
checking account of course
um but I do allow them to hold me
accountable on these things so
um I think it's it's and maybe your dad
you know what your dad would probably
give you some great perspective too
probably provide some great like
insights into if you said Dad I'd love
some accountability if he said hey the
bank has this mechanism that if you need
to spend more than 1500 bucks at a given
time or more than 500 at a given time
um I it requires a second person or a
text message in an authorization code or
something put in some barriers for
yourself and I want you to know this
just because you have bipolar too that
doesn't mean you're insane everybody I
know who is successful has barriers and
uh boundaries and accountability in
their life I don't know anybody who runs
Reckless
you were talking about the baby steps
that's um that's inside baseball lingo
for folks who are trying to get out of
debt and following the great Dave
Ramsey's plan Dave still runs expenses
by his wife they hold each other
accountable and hey I want to buy this
we're not buying that I want to buy that
we're not buying that they still hold
each other accountable still has that
still has that
guy's got more money than he's beyond
beyond comprehension
but he still has accountability in his
life
um I still have
Lane Norton in Sal de Stefano and I
still got Jordan Syed I got these guys
in my life that I talked to about
nutrition I talked about working out I
need boundaries I gotta get some help I
gotta get some wisdom I gotta get some
insight I gotta put some things in my
house I can't have gummy candy in the
house because I'll eat all of it all the
time so I just don't have it in there
that's not a function of bipolar one or
two that's that's a function of being a
disciplined person and knowing yourself
well enough to know what level of
discipline and accountability and
hurdles in my life do I need to be
successful
the goal isn't to like become so
hardcore I don't need hurdles I think
that's a waste of time and energy
it's to know which hurdles do I need and
where do I need them in what areas of my
life and who can I rely on to hold me
accountable in those Seasons that to me
that's that is a Cornerstone of a
well-lived life that's why you hear me
always talking about connection
connection you got to make friends you
got to make friends that's why you gotta
have people in your life that call you
out
and for those of us who struggle with
making friends sometimes and that might
be a counselor might be a minister that
might be a mentor of where you work
that get people in your life Lauren I
need to say one more time so proud of
you
I'm so proud of you you give light and
hope to everybody struggling with
bipolar
like okay I can get on a medication
routine I can take care of my body and
get some people in my life I can start
making some decisions I can pay off my
debts I can make amends and have a
relationship with my dad my family
amazing amazing so proud of you Lauren
you call anytime I'm here for you thanks
everybody we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com deloney today to
get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back
and they're dragging me back to it good
folks it's time to take a return
to factor your friends let's do it
we gotta is that the new grass look at
the new graph fantastic man I know it
looks awesome yeah
yeah if you're listening to this on
podcasts some brand new graphics are
behind me it's awesome hey and for
everybody reaching out um this comes out
you know several weeks after we record
it but we changed the podcast feed photo
to more like an old punk rock cover and
man everybody's reached out
I'm so grateful everybody's super
positive about it I love it I love it
it's finally feeling like more like home
more like me so that's that's fantastic
all right so today we are talking about
this
um this occurred to me about 10 years
ago I was working at University
um and my students were coming in and
coming in and coming in and this is when
10 to 15 years ago is when the a shift
began to happen inside my dean of
students office
um my res life offices when I was
sitting with these students who were
really struggling and so many of the
struggles came down to financial
struggles
like at the end of the day I've got ADHD
I've got depression I've got this I've
got anxiety I'm struggling with this I'm
struggling with this I'm struggling with
this and it would always distill down to
we can't afford to be here
and I realized at the root of of that
money question was I'm about to lose all
my friends in community I'm about to get
off track and have to leave school and I
don't know what comes next my mom and
dad are hassling me all the time because
they can't afford College I can't afford
this place
so that's where that's the organic
nature of this conversation started with
me and at the same time I was getting my
graduate degree my wife was Dr deloney
before I was and so we had six degrees
between us
um we both had bachelor's degrees and
master's degrees and phds and we just
paid for them straight through and I
realized I could use my student loan
money to pay rent to I use them as like
a consolidation loan and I put all my
truck and my credit cards I put
everything in this big bucket and
I looked up all sudden and we owed six
figures we owed a hundred some thousand
dollars into the government right in
student loans and then
my wife and I both got fancy jobs
so we had to get new cars
and so uh I bought two cars we had I had
an F-150 on payments and I had got my
wife a RAV4 uh on payments and we've by
the way we've never been cool car people
those those cars for us were like whoa
because we don't care and then of course
we had to buy a new house so we got a
house
and when I trace the timeline back when
I backed out 30 000 feet from
what I would call when I just fell apart
I had a lot of anxiety a lot and I had
some trauma I hadn't dealt with I had
some relationship issues I hadn't dealt
with I had some some major issues where
trust was broken in my life in some
powerful ways that I was still wrestling
with
but when I drilled down to the
neurophysiology what was my brain trying
to tell me
screaming at the top of its lungs trying
to get my attention
sounding those anxiety alarms my heart
is racing every
it's my body new hey you owe a 110 or
106 whatever 110
000 in educational expenses that you can
never discharge with bankruptcy you are
stuck you will pay these off forever
five to six to seven hundred bucks a
month hey you owe on these depreciating
assets you owe ten thousand dollars on
this one and twenty thousand or
seventeen thousand on this one
you can't even afford a house oh you
just bought a house that's another
hundred and sixty thousand so we owed
hundreds of thousands of dollars
and it never occurred to me until
looking back in retrospect that my body
knew I worked at a university right as
all these conversations about hey you
can't say that you're going to lose your
job all those things were starting
and my body knew hey deloney you're kind
of a loud mouth and if you say the wrong
thing
you're gonna get fired if you get fired
your family loses their house they lose
their cars you all won't be able to eat
you have a new son now you have a kid
everything changes and so my body knew
my foot my my prefrontal cortex if you
will my PFC I'll simplify it
um it knew hey I got a good deal on the
APR on this my interest rate on my house
was pretty low my interest rate on my
student loans was pretty high but it
just globally it was pretty low
um my interest rate on my cars wasn't
bad so my brain my my thinking brain
knew I got some good deals on this stuff
but
for simplicity's sake my amygdala the
part of my brain that is sounding the
alarms that is always scanning the
environment all of the time to let me
know I'm not safe
right you ever walk into a room and you
just know whoa I need to get out of here
or a guy walks into a room and you just
know your body knows that guy's not safe
that guy's not okay
or
um you grew up in an abusive household
and then another guy comes swaggering in
some part of you're in and you just your
body's like Boo get out now like
that was ringing off the hook for me all
the time
and when your alarms are going off and
you don't know what they're what what
they're from like why they're going off
it comes out as anger
comes out as blame well if you would
just pick everything up well if you
would just do this if those people
whoever those people happen to be if
they would just fill in the blank I
Don't Care What They're I don't care
what you're gonna say
if that if that if that political party
would
all of those feelings are your body
trying to get your attention
and because we have
um the
media industrial complex that we have
now always just spoon feeding us stories
as to why our bodies feel that way over
and over it's because of this it's
because of this it's because of this
I was talking in my one of my close
buddies uh Dr Lane Norton the other day
the the number of insane
insane
things people reach out to him for for
weight loss ideas and how to get in
shape how to how to lose body fat
it it will Boggle your mind people will
do anything
to not just
um
eat less than they need and uh or eat
exactly what they need controller
calories and exercise people they'll go
to the ends of the Earth similarly
we will blame we will point fingers we
will create new things we will get
really really busy we will drink we will
just Netflix ourselves to death we will
like hide behind academic journals which
is what I did for years and years and
years we will do anything and our body
is screaming us and screaming us and
screaming us and so one of the keys here
and um
I don't want this to sound like a long
book pitch this is me just trying to
teach a little bit
one of the keys that I write about in
building a non-interest life one of the
choices we have to make on a daily basis
on a monthly basis on a weekly basis on
an annual basis on a life basis
is this idea of choosing freedom
and I need you to hear me say
um
if you don't owe anybody any money
your body goes
you can get fired and they're not going
to take away your house
to take away your cars
you work for yourself and business can
slow to a crawl
and it's annoying it's not catastrophic
and
you've heard me say over and over the
title of the great Bessel vanderkolk's
book the body keeps the score but the
body keeps the score
and no matter how good you think I'm not
gonna pay off my mortgage because it's
at a three percent rate and I can invest
the rest over here cool go go do those
mathematical gymnastics do a bunch of
cartwheels with your calculators and
make yourself feel good your brain knows
we owe 300 000 on this mortgage and
we're not safe
there's a reason why all throughout
human history
tribes and family lineages when they got
property it was passed down for
Generations I'll never forget a
conversation I had with a sociologist
from Romania we were sitting by each
other in a climate science meeting and
we were talking about soil and stuff
like that in the United States and she
leaned over to me and she said I will
never understand the US's relationship
to its soil and I thought she was
talking about uh you know the poison we
spray on our foods and all that she
wasn't
she said in in her home country
you had to prove lineage to buy land it
was that precious
you can't just sell it to anybody you
want to from any other country you can't
just give that away that's so precious
that's what keeps us safe because it's
ours our bodies are able to go
when all else fails I can go home
and when you owe money to somebody
your body knows
and if we want to take the choose
Freedom argument one step further
how many of you your your in-laws are
still telling you what you're going to
do for the holidays
how many of you still have friends that
are like oh my gosh are you seriously
gonna wear that we're going out on
Wednesday and you don't want to go
you're tired you miss your husband you
miss your wife you want to see your kids
actually
but you go anyway because you Outsource
that how many of you work at a toxic
workplace I know millions of you do
because I hear from you my friend King
Cole and hears from you
all over the country
every month Monday your heart beat your
heart rate your BPM just goes up 10
beats because it's like ah here we go
man
I gotta go into this awful place
when you Outsource your joy when you
Outsource your life when you Outsource
how you feel when you Outsource your
thoughts your body keeps the score
or how many of you your lives are
dictated by what the soccer coach says
your practice schedule is going to be
how many of you are your lives are
dictated by what your pastor says your
church schedule and your evening
schedule and your weekend schedule all
like they run your calendar for you
how many of you are so up to your
eyeballs in school activities in karate
and horseback riding that your calendar
is so chaotic you're not free
and so
one of these core chapters in this book
one of these choices we have to make is
I got to choose freedom I have to look
at places in my life where I am hooked
and I have to consciously do the work to
unhook myself that might mean I gotta
spend five years working three jobs so
that I owe nobody anything
that might mean I'm gonna owe nobody
anything so that I can quit this job
that is killing me and go do something
else I'm going to sit down with my wife
and I'm going to we're going to clear
our calendar we're going to start to
finish or I'm single I'm going to get
with three or four of my friends one or
two of my friends we're gonna go through
our calendar start to finish what do I
have to do
what do I want to do
and then we're going to backfill the
rest and that may mean looking at your
kids and saying hey this this year we're
stopping the madness we're just gonna do
one thing
you can play soccer you can do violin
you can do piano we're gonna do one
thing
or you can do one instrument and you can
do one activity that's it
but we're gonna save the money we're
gonna save
hear me say this a Cornerstone of
building a non-anxious life
is choosing freedom
and I don't mean that in the political
sense I don't mean that in the
um
I don't know dramatic sense
I mean literally
and I was in Costa Rica recently
and I'll leave you with this
my son and I were walking down down down
this sidewalk in this really busy street
um and people were bustling and going
and going bustling and there's a lot of
motorcycles driving by and
he said dad this just feels different
here
I was like yeah you're right man and I
thought it was because because we were
on a trip
and then I said you know what Hank
everyone we've talked to
is so insanely proud to live here
they're so insanely proud of their
community
and where we were staying was at the
base of a giant volcano that's active
it's erupted within the last however
many years
and I would ask folks just from the
folks who were you know carrying bags to
the folks who were like the the leaders
and the restauranteers
like what happens if that thing goes off
and they were like
well this is over
it was just this and I was like yeah but
but
they had completely unhooked from this
obsession with we have to control
everything all the time everything's
about
it was just hey right now we live in
Beauty
I don't know anybody anything
our our cultural ethos is kindness and
Hospitality everybody's welcome
I'm not gonna fight you
we are just going to be at peace and if
you need some fruit off my tree you can
come grab it
every Community uh every every little
neighborhood every Community every
little town had four things had a church
a bar a school and a soccer field and I
thought man that may be maybe that may
be the key to life
but I tell you all that to say I met
with people who had very very very
little
who sat at the base of a big volcano
that can go off at any time
and they were completely free they had
chosen freedom
they had chosen to let go the wheel
they don't know anybody thing
they were beholden to
and so if you want to live a non-anxious
life I want you to look around your life
I want you to look around your
relationships where are you not free
write those things down
be specific I owe a whole bunch of money
I live in an unsafe neighborhood I'm in
an unsafe scary marriage and I'm not
free to say what I think to let my needs
be heard I'm not free to walk about my
house
where are you not free
and if you've got a
group of friends or a partner who will
sit with you and kind of unpack those
awesome if you don't
find a minister find a counselor find
somebody in your life you can sit on and
talk to
call my friends a better help reach out
to somebody
[Music]
and say I'm not safe
not free
so that's today's fact for your friends
that's one of six of the choices you can
make pick up building a non-anxious life
go to johnboy.com pick it up but
even if you don't buy the book that's
fine
I want this for you
I can't want it more than you do but I
really want it for you
I want you to choose freedom
[Music]
peace we'll be right back
if you've listened to my show any amount
of time you've definitely heard me talk
about Thorn Thorne is an incredible
supplement company that makes what I
think are the best supplements in the
game I've taken Thorn for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcasts
or just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming the next great
thing for all sorts of ailments almost
all of those claims and products are
either lying not good products or just a
waste of your money Thorne is one of the
very few supplement companies that make
Pure Clean tested and backed by science
supplements no fluff no gimmicks no
nonsense Thorn is what I take personally
and it's what I give to my kids and make
no mistake supplements of this quality
cost more than the nonsense you see in
gas stations so I've partnered with
Thorne for an incredible 25 off discount
for our delonia listeners go to
thorn.com you slash deloni choose what
you want add it to your cart create an
account and when you check out 25 off
will be knocked off of the entire order
and here's the best part that discount
sticks around for Life go to thorn.com
the letter U slash deloni check it out
all right we are back let's go out to
Cleveland Ohio and talk to the Great and
Powerful John
what in the world is up John how we
doing
oh man I guess I guess we're doing this
aren't we let's do this man let's do it
what's up brother how are you
uh I'm doing pretty good awesome
I guess a little nervous to be uh to be
talking to you here but I guess we just
uh just get into it huh hey Swan dot no
don't Swan Dive you might hit your head
on the bottom Let's uh Cannonball
Cannonball is the great Kevin Dillard
says let's do it
um well I'll I'll start with my question
and then maybe give you some context
okay to put the question around
uh so the question is is how do I
reconcile with my sister
um
I don't reconcile even there's a really
good word there but the the context of
it is that my uh about a year ago now
yeah probably probably more than a year
ago now
it came out that my sister was carrying
on an affair
um with another married man
um and uh my brother-in-law found out
about it and it ended up they they their
marriage ended in divorce
um recently
and um
Dan I just I lost a lot of respect for
my sister and I've honestly have lost a
lot of respect for my parents through
this whole thing
and I wish it was something that I could
you know just kind of ignore and just
kind of go about my business so you guys
do what you want to do but you know our
family is pretty close and you know we
gotta actually uh family vacation coming
up in uh in a couple of weeks that uh my
brother-in-law who was not invited to
and I guess sides have been drawn to
this whole thing and I feel like I'm you
know pretty firmly behind my
brother-in-law because to me like this
all happened to him he didn't choose for
any of this and it really infuriates me
that
um my parents seem to have taken my
sister's side through all this and
I think that the
um my parents are very very concerned
about maintaining a relationship with
their daughter and with their grandkids
and to me that's like
I don't know I wish my I wish my sister
would show some remorse for what she did
to her family but it doesn't feel like
she is and have you talked to your
sister John have you talked to her
um it's like a private conversation okay
I think all of this is on pause until
you do that
and this is a big enough deal that
[Music]
um
I would get on an airplane and go fly
and sit with her
it says go to coffee
this is a big enough deal where I would
go visit and and at least hear her out
because what you're doing right now is
you are you've heard one side of the
story from brother-in-law yeah
um I can tell you after dealing with
this forever it's never never just one
side there's always another side to it
two
um
austrous ostracization that's probably
not the right I'm not saying that the
right way I'm cutting people off
almost never leads to behavior change
and there's a difference between I love
you
I love you I'm always going to be your
brother
I'm not gonna go on vacation with you
but I'm I I Will Always Love You
and when they say well if you're gonna
love me then you have to do everything
that I say no I don't no I don't
I'm gonna draw some boundaries
but I think you can only do that after
you've done the loving adult grown-up
plus we're brother and sister thing
which is I'm gonna go meet with you in
person say get get like what happened
man
and you can you can walk away from those
interactions knowing with a pretty good
sense of what comes next
and it might be Hey sister I I'm not I'm
not comfortable bringing my family
around some strange new guy who's
married to somebody else
uh I'm not comfortable with that
and what you have to balance is
you had this picture of one big happy
family and somebody else blew it up and
you're pissed at them for blowing up
your life which is fair
but be careful that doesn't lead into
you just throwing grenades and rocks at
people because
um you're gonna be throwing grenades and
rocks at them but you're the one that's
going to absorb those explosions
um you can't hold your family like you
can't hold your family together it's
been blown up and so now we have to
create something new does that make
sense
yeah let me let me throw another wrinkle
at you okay
um
she uh my my sister
uh only communicates through written
and that's kind of something that has
made me angry because I guess not a
piece of it because like
you know she she communicates everything
through email Facebook posts or text
messages and that's something that you
know I'm like if you want to talk to me
come talk to me
um or something you want to say talk to
me like I don't I can't do this whole
email except except you're the one with
the problem
yeah so it needs to go the other way
I I think you're 100 right I would not
communicate to somebody electronically
like that
I wouldn't do that and so if somebody
says this is my new boundary
um I will only talk via Facebook and
text mention that's a new bit that's a
new thing that's come out in the last
few years by the way these strange
family boundaries like I only feel safe
texting okay that's fine but when you
say that you are opting out of
relationship with me at this time
because I only talk in person to the
people I love of course I send funny
text messages back and forth my sister
texted me last night because Astros got
Verlander back that's all great but when
it comes to substantive things we talk
on the phone we go we talk in person
we don't do long I don't do in fact one
of my mentors uh Michael Sean rock man
one of the awesomest guys in the world
um he always had like a piece of tape on
his on his computer and if the email was
too long he just he would wouldn't even
read it he would just reply like hey set
up a meeting
like I'm not gonna do all of this in
email I'm just gonna I'm just gonna do
it in a person and so I think it's fair
to say if she chooses that I think it's
fair to text her back and say I want to
come visit you and talk with you and
take you to coffee would you meet with
me and if she says I only am going to do
this via Facebook or whatever you can
write her back and say this is too big
of a deal to continue this exchange when
you're ready to talk in person I can't
wait and I'll be there
and let that be the end of it
because she's drawn this weird boundary
and you've gotten pissed that she drew a
boundary
that's fine I wouldn't spend one second
energy being upset with her I would just
draw my own boundary back
is it like so and I hope you hear me say
this and I'm not trying to be dismissive
I understand how bad this hurts it
messes up everything
um
but also I I just wouldn't give all this
energy in angst into energy and angst
like I want to hear what you have to say
and if you don't want to talk to me then
you're opting out of relationship with
me that breaks my heart makes me sad it
kind of confirms what I was thinking
anyway about your character but man
you're going through some stuff cool
hey Mom and Dad everybody we're gonna my
family we're gonna opt out of the family
vacation this year I appreciate you guys
it's just it's everything's pretty hot
um sister doesn't even want to talk in
person I'm we're gonna opt out we're
gonna do our own thing this year we love
you guys and we look forward to getting
back together next year
that's that
yeah that'd be some
I guess sacrifice one of the reason why
I was kind of swallowing my pride or
whatever is just going along with it go
to the family vacations because
I've got two kids and my kids and her
kids really only see each other once a
year at these Vacations so I've always
kind of but hey let's go because it
causes need to have a relationship with
each other at least at least in my
opinion I 100 agree but if she's opting
out of relationship with you guys
there's not a lot you can do
yeah that's true because you end up
compromising your value so yes in a
perfect world
cousins are all Linked UP
it's the way it should be
but if somebody opts out of that
relationship
if somebody's not trustworthy if
somebody doesn't tell the truth if
somebody will only connect via what like
I can't I can't I'm not going to
compromise my values and the values of
my family to prop up this picture of
what I want to be true
um it's just it's just it's
heartbreaking
and it's really hard in the fog I mean
the smoke of of of a raging fire to
understand that it will burn out
so this one summer that you might have
to miss on the family vacation
the cousins will get together
this isn't going to be a forever thing
it'll get together they'll have tons of
fun it'll be a blast
they will get together maybe not maybe
not this year that's fine
but let's don't let's don't burn
everything to the ground trying to prop
up a picture that's been burned down
picture's gone man
things are going to be different
and my hope is let's let the adults
um
let's let the adults be adults and let's
dig into this thing and figure it out
together
I'm proud of you man I hate this for you
I hate this for you but let's get on the
phone and it's worth it's worth the
Southwest flight man
um if you if you don't live in the same
neighbor if you live in the same
neighborhood dude I'd try to get
together tonight but it's worth the
flight to sit down with your sister face
to face and say hey I miss you are you
okay what happened
and she tells you nah I just cheated on
my husband with a married dude
YOLO One Life to Live whatever you can
say hey that's assistant
I love you you're my sister that's not
something I'm going to be a part of
I can't be a part of that I don't want
my kids around that
um and I want more for you and I love my
brother-in-law so he's gonna stay my
friend
and um if you choose to walk away that
you can choose to do that and then you
can make those boundary judgments right
but let's let's don't throw rocks until
we've had a chance to sit at a table
with somebody
and by the way that goes for all of us
I'm talking to myself here this is me
talking to the man in the mirror
um
let's have a conversation first before
we throw any Rock
we'll be right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show from the Great and Powerful
Queen the song is I Want to Break Free
I want to break free from your lies
you're so self-satisfied I don't need
you I've got to break free God knows I
want to break free I've fallen in love
for the first time and this time I know
it's for real
God knows I've fallen in love it's
strange but it's true I can't get over
you the way you love me like you do but
I have to be sure when I walk out the
door ah I want to be free
I Want to Break Free
is this you saying you want to quit the
show Jenna I understand
I understand strange way it's a strange
way to quit your job but uh well played
Millennial she just quiet quit in case
you're wondering love you guys stay in
school with on your drugs bye
[Music]
foreign